Bernie Sanders going all in on his
controversial plan to let felons
including terrorists like the Boston
bomber vote from prison Bernie now
taking it even further with these
comparisons I said that because the
right to vote is essential if you are a
citizen you have the right to vote and
that is a right we must protect because
we know the history of this country we
know that women didn't have the right to
vote we know that african-americans
didn't have the right to vote Sanders is
also slamming a Florida bill requiring
felons to pay court fees before becoming
eligible to vote as quote racist and
unconstitutional okay what we just did
what the frustrating thing was yesterday
those are two different things
what Bernie Sanders is talking about is
people in prison mean allowed to vote
the thing in Florida is not good it is a
bill that is passed by the the House
version there's going the state Senate
version is different it is separate it
is it is for people who have gotten out
of prison who have paid their debt to
society they are out of prison and they
are trying to put additional constraints
on them that is a separate topic from
what Bernie Sanders is talking about
sorry so here's my point to you which is
Bernie Sanders is moving this
conversation incrementally voting rights
I'm not breathing you agree with felons
historic stories spelling voting - once
they get out of prison of course yes but
that is not what Bernie Sanders was the
initial thing the other day and him
moving the conversation incrementally
it's to try to save face for what
happened the other day because the
entire Democratic Party now is like whoa
wait what did he say I would have to
answer that and I wonder what Joe Biden
will say I bet he'll have a better
answer well I think you may have a
different answer but I think it's a
conversation starter boy everybody's
talking about it Dana and I would get
mad about it and you got to say you know
what Bernie you have done something here
because
good job America isn't having this
conversation America America there's no
there's no the Boston bomber in the next
election would make a great president
he'd be a progressive candidate you can
make a caricature but the real point I
think that in fact there's an important
election topic about citizenship and
Bernie like Earl Warren the former Chief
Justice all say you don't base it upon
who you want or you this crime or that
good one now you're arguing the point
you were arguing the point before you
were trying to switch that same point
let's argue the point though on do you
think the Boston bomber should be able
to vote in 2020 I do I think I haven't
considered acceptable because question
yes or no I think that your citizenship
rights are not to be revoked because you
don't like me and if you say have a gun
in prison too because that's a Second
Amendment right 2020 just want to say
look 22 states right now will restore a
felons voting rights after up for a
period after release in fact 14 states
that say you lose your life we're for
that all right we've been talking about
this for three days now and as you guys
know I spend a lot of time with inmates
and I correspond with them regularly so
I've gotten a lot of emails from them in
the last two days first of all they
watch this show flaming liberal they
like animals our great city
jokes they should be watching the five
oh that's that's another right that
should be deprived we don't need the
rating we're like number one in the
country we don't there's three sections
of this conversation there's there's the
violent terrorists whatever voting from
prison there's the incarcerated
nonviolent offenders that really this
conversation is about and there's the
post incarceration subject to the fines
and everything which is a ridiculous yes
secondary imprisonment and my point in
bringing that up is that there's a lot
of sentiments that in the nonviolent
realm you guys not everyone in there is
like the Grim Reaper you know can I
respond you can respond to that I think
you're making you're actually addressing
the point that Bernie has screwed up so
badly the problem is there's a
perception of the left that they are
soft in crime on crime
they're anti law enforcement let's face
it they were anti cops everything so no
one takes it seriously when somebody
like but when Bernie Sanders comes out
and says that it fulfills the stereotype
it's a terrible thing to run on whereas
if a Republican came up and said you
know it's time for prison reform and I'm
interested in those nonviolent offenders
having the right to vote everybody goes
well it's a Republican normally they're
strong on crime so maybe I'll listen to
him you see it's it's it's a perception
issue just add one other senators
Heitkamp and Donnelly who lost in the
midterms
they are Democrats they are starting a
new entity to try to help Democrats talk
to people in rural America well guess
what here's your first lesson
what did mayor Pete say when he was
asked on that same night in the CNN Town
Hall do you think that felons the right
to vote you know in while they're
incarcerated he said no no that's how
you talk to people in America and you
know everywhere for that matter to jail
we have to the fact that these these
guys are they're counted in these
legislative populations that's the other
thing it's just not about any larger
freedom taken away from you because
you're not allowed movement you your
freedom has been taken away you cannot
leave therefore I don't see the
difference between saying that you've
been also can't vote exactly because
then I should be able to
my gun too right if I want have my
voting rights I want to have my gun you
can't have an honest conversation if you
go yeah we're all liars
[Laughter]
you understand you're just twisting the
jonathan rhys Jonathan Swift read the
Constitution because the constant